five years ago one of our section
managers came up with this idea to do a
pumpkin carving contest the rules were
very simple you could pick out your
pumpkin the day before so everyone got
to know they can measure their pumpkin
they could look at it but they wouldn't
actually get access to their pumpkin
until the day of the contest and you
have one hour with your pumpkin
these are mechanical engineers they're
hard work people they love building
stuff
[Music]
pumpkin back
a lot of these things are obviously
their own money that they're spending
out of their pocket all the mechanisms
all the tools that they're using you
know we can't supply that sort of stuff
the pumpkins and everything so it shows
a lot of dedication
[Music]